prende tutti ragazzi e prevenuti questo
video sono fa vj e se vi state chiedendo
perché già le maniche corte anche se
sono 20 gradi sotto zero e perché perché
perché perché perché io c'ho il fisico
io c'ho il fisico no no no vabbè tutte
squallida parte siamo tornati su al in
isole shawn e prego gesù che questa sia
la fine perché mio dio usare il relatore
per turare a torre sentite parabola c'è
qualcuna prevedere digitale terrestre di
ogni caso mi ha preso per un antennista
ascoltami zio allinea mista c'è papà che
non è possibile entrata la cosa mi a
secco quale entrata dove per quando a
questa perfetto cioè ragazzi ditemi voi
se è possibile che io debba allineare
delle parabole devo andare fuori con la
tuta sarà veramente figo fare questa
cosa problema è che va bene lo spazio
più sicuro che guadagna almeno non ci ha
neanche mi caga le balle almeno quello
sì è un casco tipo quello che metti in
moto sempre effetto lo vedo che lo fa
guardando la se fosse un alieno sarà
l'espulsione di colle approcci però ca9
in sommi sparasse una supposta nel
deretano vabbè che permettono a parte
gli scherzi con tasti lamela carta
igienica che vola nello spazio è
bellissimo ho fatto tutto sto bordello
asi perfetto ragazzi impariamo storicità
e poi me ne vado a fan culo perché non è
possibile 85 giusto si perfetto dovrebbe
niente non è giusto un cazzo sì sì a
posto funziona ragazzi funziona la
televisione perché adesso si vedono i
programmi come affanculo al resto da
adesso possono tornare a casa almeno ma
sti cazzi nell'alto e mista c'era
abbastanza tempo fa prendere
i canali in hd led tranquilla zia
d'ossola riparando parabole mettiti in
posizione
ce l'ho fatto solo sin sopra aggiustare
una parabola perfetto per fare una
scenata poi non è che va beh
l'importante ragazzi che siamo usciti
domanda riccardo tra l'altro cos'è
ragazzi ascolta fratel nonno del cazzo
vai zio non ti conviene tanto vabbè mi
fa molto piacere il fatto che sia
tornato alien si apre la porta a merda
non sia pregarono si apre perfetto
schiacciavo schiacciavo una donna prega
brega dove cazzo sparito caso non ho ben
capito dov'è finito ma mi devo levare
dover nell'ascesa no non devi rompere il
cazzo a me ascolta binomi che ha visto
la prima donna se mi faccia di uccidere
poi ti ammazza voi dovremmo essere alla
fine in teoria se riesco a tornare non
ce la farò mai nella mia vita
maledizione sì sì ascoltatevi ragazzi ma
se no no no non mi sta aprendo per il
culo no mi sta aprendo ragazzi no no ed
affanculo riprende non mi prenderanno mi
ha visto tanto mi ha visto l'ha visto no
no no no no no scherzavo ruggia cosa
volutamente di morire balis è mica che
cartella notato smorto vivo sono
creativo veloce velocissimo bigia che
culo che botta di culo sono vivo come
faccia mi chiama dato una testata
incredibile velocissimi velo dove stiamo
andando
riccardo è morto ragazzi emo e morto
riccardo dispiace di averti bruciato
quello di giugno non voler volevo ma non
troppo varei funerali volentieri ma c'è
dove è qua c'è praticamente al nono zio
allora ascoltami con trovarmi cascione
sora trovata porta perfetto no no no no
no no non lo schiacciava l'ho preso
adesso non ridi più essere no scherzavo
scattavo
un fucile della chicco e della chi è
finto sto scherzando madonna mia no va
bene lo corretto però va di qua di qua
veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce prima
che ci stupri nolano serva solo chi è
questo ragazzo è un tizio che si è
seduto che sei successo si è cagato
addosso ragazzi no non ti azzardare
aspra e vabbé tapino il culto mi
dispiace ciao ciao a prossima via via
via via via via via via via non mi ha
visto amelia vera visto lui perché non
posso essere io l'unico stronzo tra non
so neanche io non so neanche dove sono
entrato la gara bellissima
ok dove siamo finiti frega non aprire
stata scattata lo stavo scherzando non
aprire non aprire lo stavo scherzando
giuro che schiacciava dove perché sento
bordello ma non c'è nessuno
sto scherzando che bello non ha visto è
andato è sparito ragazze e spari dove è
andato a caso i suoi dirigenti mi poteva
ammazzarmi in 20 modi diversi non mi ha
ucciso bene non mi ha visto avrà forse
avrà pensato che è stato un accendino
non so o qualcuno ha mangiato piccante
non voglio sapere per cosa ha pensato va
bene così ragazzi se sopravvivo a sta
cosa voglio 12 stato non solo ha fatto a
sopravvivere ragazzi che è stato e le
voglio adesso tutte cioè se fosse lo
raggiungo li tira una botta regala tincu
lo vivo dal non è morto né morto né
morto è morto
non ho sentito niente nessuno vero noi
assistito agli han deve sentire
un picasso fino al midollo cosa sei già
strato ma veramente non ti volevo
insultare questa voce o del rispetto per
te credimi che dovevo fare avanti e
indietro per prendere un ascensore
ditemelo non ci sto più facendo
impazzendo basta
vabbè però non solo i pestarmi anche un
piede non so già che ci sei
trovo una strada alternativa per il
tempo tanto io lo sapevo che succedeva
stare lo sapevo ci avrei scommesso tanto
in tutti gli orli horror e così ho fatto
di tutto l'elettricista l'antennista
adesso faccio l'ascensorista
giorno accolti zio lei è molto figo mi
tolga le mani di dosso screanzato niente
lascia che ti aiuto una guardatina
stupro il culo la mori bravo e bello a
riceve le botte intenso ci devi dai
[ __ ] android e non ho idea di dove
sia vita ok ho trovato forse perfetta
alves colti c'è un alieno brutto che sta
per arrivare
i consiglieri fare attenzione senza il
favore possiamo giocare la partita
insieme prima dove colori dove lo chef
luca ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta
incredibile ai ragazzi con con ste
tessere l'accesso cominciava ho infilato
più tessere da 100
merda
giorno a scafati non lascia il solito
sbaglio ma visto ma visto che mi ha
visto merda ma via via via via via via
via mi sa che mi ha visto sicuro via
viole ragazzino dove dove dovete e non
ce la farò mai regali andato via
perfetto nel possibile veloce di quattro
palle scolti cosa posso fare per posso
offrirgli un caffè sconta zio si
andrebbe un caffè macchiato non
macchiato macchiato e non macchiato e lo
sapevo che ognuno dei tre cioè scotolati
facciamo sta roba ragazzi perché non ne
usciamo più sotto
ok fermo fermo passa di qua stronzo
gianni chiarato fuoco e spari a caso
ragazzi in chat ormai lo sapete vero mi
ha visto non gira gira gira mica che se
gira che culo no eh vabbè ma c'è la
scritta bastardo sulla testa
ce l'ho fatta ma visto ma visto eva
qualcuno non è possibile però si è
impallato pure il gioco meraviglioso
gente di merda che non sei altro orali
sul fuoco sei sopra
ma cos'ha detto ma cosa c'è nel cervello
sto ragazzo cioè quota di culo è bello
quando succedono stanno seriamente mi
diverto un figo ei baby tanto non mi
prendi compreso ha condotto ma serio ma
[ __ ]
ma come fa prendermi d'arco
siamo vai vai vai vai vai vai sì sì se
passo posta minchia bravo track attracca
misto bene basta non ne posso più
raggiunge il terminal spaziale basta
dimmi che quando raggiungo sto cazzo di
termina finisce perché non ce la posso
più fare da sé basta guarda che obbliga
tipo mai visto proprio non avrei mai
detto idraulico anche l'idraulico adesso
faccio l'elettricista in dante mista
[ __ ] a tutto come ti permetti di
toccarmi più presente e vuole che mi
stupra qualcosa vada sono sopravvissuta
un alieno miss mi ha stuprato un robot
madonna che bordello regala già posso
fare ciò il kit mesto che facendo un kit
medico fanno del male a qualcuno forse
no
cazzo è andato è scappato veloce come
salvare poi mi salvare mi ammazzo la
famiglia merda no no no no sei il
[ __ ] stronzo mi sono cadute le cuffie
obiettivo aggiornato alla chiusa d'aria
non mi ha visto visto mi ha visto adesso
ma visto sicuro per forza non è un
[ __ ] è un [ __ ]
mi hai visto non vi è chi devo sparare
in faccia o no fammi capire non ho visto
credevo che se non ne ha visto invece
stronzo lunga devi bruciare anche tua
mamma via via dentro ed ha storditi
porca [ __ ] che in un cie verso io vi
giuro che questo gioco non prenderlo
lancio dalla fine non c'è verso sto
gioco fatico a capirlo avevano
impossibile domanda devo andare nuovo a
lui proprio è una presa per il culo
calma quanti cazzo siete perché ho
chiuso la porta in faccia tra l'altro
bellissimi vai vai vai vai no no no no
no no troppi troppi
[Musica]
sì dai brucia ma cosa non sono morto
veloce carli carli
non ci posso credere mai non ci posso
credere mai si si oh mio dio ragazzi
veloce cazzo cosa no no non ci posso mai
prendere lega non ci fosse mai che non è
possibile non è fottutamente possibile
non è fottutamente post ma sono morto no
forse non doveva andare così io sono
morto pochi potevano farmi fare sta cosa
sin dall'inizio se mi prendevano ma
adesso dovranno far bene ma mi sono
anche diverse ma veramente
ma se il serio cioè dall'inizio che
scappo da sto deficiente
buongiorno non potevo fare così
dall'inizio porca [ __ ] va beh no dai
veramente a partiti sti cazzo di ragni
di uccido la mamma no no dai troppi rai
libro vedo dico no
ok via via via via via via g no no no no
no no no così si è morto avevo vinto se
prendevo la tuta era finito il gioco
perché ero riuscito a uscire
dove vado no no no morire male tutti
quanti c'è un punto dove salvare il suo
gioco di merda ad andare avanti
tranquillamente ok giorno non mi sono
liberato e sono anno prende solo lattes
nel frigo stavo scherzando veramente sto
caricando e fammi fine di caricare poi
dispari in faccia bravo è andato via lui
bellissimo non ha guardato in faccia non
mi ha detto niente
secondo me la torres regia sulla terra
sta bevendo sorbetti noi siamo merda
cosa è successo
l'olivo ho preso solo un pezzo di
metallo nella faccia ma per carità di
dio sono vivo ok bene a post trauma la
zia non ti prego non gridare a cazzo
così successo niente vedi tutto
tranquillo via di qua e il ventilatore
che fa caldo giusto 60 ecco e sabato
cristo lo dico anch'io mica è passato un
treno poi mi sono uscire viva da qui ma
guarda non è l'obiettivo dall'inizio del
gioco questo è l'obiettivo era quello di
comprare un gelato ragazzi a jean
perdere che è meglio andiamo avanti
perché passano i treni
mi piacciono i treni
è passato davvero vince non pensavo
treno alta velocità 99 15 in arrivo da
[ __ ] sono vivo sono dove cosa sono
ci è mancato guarda io non andrei più da
parrucchiere davanti agli altri i
capelli e qua sono tre non lo sono a
posto
possibilmente che non passi mentre salgo
la scala
ok grazie molto gentili lignano questo
gioco e basta non ne posso più veramente
non hai idea di qua sì ci ho fatto l'ho
trovato anche noi siamo qui che ci sarà
su tornato qui
ragazzi se vado io giorni ci posso
credere
prendi sta minchia di tutta e spera che
un alieno non ti prenda dalla testa
possibilmente guarda in alto perché non
vorrei mai fai più lenta e mi raccomando
che tanto non prima e non è successo
niente
guarda suo no non è successo niente
almeno stavolta grazie a dio mi ha
portato non so dove non voglio neanche
saperlo via di qui subito ce la fa
dovrei aver finito ai ragazzi non
dovrebbe esserci più niente
forse non la devo dire stare fammi
sganciarle sta minchia di astronave e
cioè torniamo tutti a casa non ne posso
più una scala scala mi chiedo questa
cella lega pokémon l'ho vista just la
scena io nei pokemon giusto
con una lentezza di quelle che minchia
posso farmi quattro caffè e una disanta
ce l'abbiamo fatta
la pianta secolare per oggi non sono
così lo faccio io io sono bravo a fare
se cose qui ma non c'e la forma ma che
può andare nello spazio cioè nel senso
proprio qua libero spero proprio di no
nella vita perché sono c'è un nel culo
basta
ho finito ho finito di dire con la frase
guardate dov'è quel pezzente guardate
che roba
lou reed ostrom fai saltare le cariche
sotto ma se c'è quel pezzente là sopra
cosa faccio saltare veloce veloce che ci
sono dai raga fai saltare sto schifo
come si fa a far saltare sar non leggere
ti prego che non c'è il tempo di leggere
non ci fate quello che uso io apro fai
da te ma cosa deve saltare però che casa
attiva veloce che ci sono quattro vari e
che ti stanno stuprando il deretano
avvitiamo tranquillamente non si fossero
lampadine tanto ci abbia un tempo mio
dio ci sono due alieni che mi sta per
mangiare la faccia se hai voglia di fare
in fretta l'ultimo e siamo a posto poi
non ne vuole tanto che costa facendo io
non so chi guardando in alto
non so neanche cosa sta facendo bene
fatto adesso adesso mi starà mangiando
il culo o no mi aggancio
ah ok mi sono sganciate perfetto in
carica carica quando saltare fanno
saltare veloce giorni scontati io ti
dispiace sempre molto usate qui merda
che è successo però c'è premi qualcosa
fai qualcosa ti prego bravo premi giorno
che bello che 6 gioca boom ne sposò
niente si è esploso però non si è
sentito che siamo nello spazio sono
scemo io la porto
l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi filmato fila non ci posso
credere è assurdo cos'è successo
mi chiamo so lanciare un petardo già che
ci sono già faccio io no
che si scagliò fatto un po di disastro
credo
se passo quello e se pasto con ragazzi
sarà da schiantare di brutto sul pianeta
ce l'abbiamo fatta
sì mi piace schiantata come non so cosa
e noi siamo vivi
madonna si è vista dallo spazio la sua
esplosione ha fatto un disastro che ho
fatta io io vengo in pace se vivo sto
andando sul ponte ragazzi ci siamo non
so come ma siamo vivi
ce l'abbiamo fottutamente fatta non c'è
più per forza perché si è schiantato è
morto tutta la vita adesso quasi monde
l'astronave con l'iniziale queste
ragazze e proprio problema navicella
quella iniziale quella del 2000 come ha
fatto salire ragazzi come ha fatto a
salire
non ci voglio credere no no striscia
striscia come ha fatto entrare più di
qualcosa per salvarmi non so cosa premi
il tasto sinistra questo mi chiami
giocherà god of war condomini tasti per
premi un tasto qualcosa prego
cosa ho fatto questo fatto come ho fatto
a salvare così mi sono sganciato sono
nello spazio no non ci credo ma chi
cazzo mi salva adesso ma veramente sceso
rimasto nello spazio dei play zia
svegliati non è che siamo in gravity
quasi risvegliati giovi fare ciò vivo o
morto sono io sono morto solo io sono
morto non capito cosa più uccido
se è finito così 10 fu tutti episodi di
alien 10 fottuti episodi dove sono
scappato da un cazzo di alieno alto
quattro metri per finire nello spazio è
una presa per il culo si è una presa per
il culo adesso si risveglierà che si
trova alle hawaii
credo [ __ ] perfetto ragazzo che ho
finito allievi solutions dopo dieci
puntate è durato un casino il finale era
una nerd 9 scherzo era bello avere
ragazzi data così purtroppo i finali non
li faccio io sono l'avrei fatto felice
più o meno per quanto si potesse fare
felice comunque ragazzi è partita a
parte il finale così è stato un gioco
della madonna
complimenti per questa roba perché ci
aveva messo gli anni per farlo anche
ragazzi ha concluso qui l'episodio spero
che il dito e spero che la serie vi sia
piaciuta in sera un'altra serie della
madonna come un filare leggermente
migliore di questo spero perché non è
possibile
fatemi sapere nei commenti che cosa ne
pensate voi del finale perché io
probabilmente uccidere o qualcuno domani
è vero che la serie vi sia piaciuto a
como santos e video piaciuto al
documento mi piace anche a face di
facebook e come
jonathan estinzione sicuri si rispetti
noi ci mettiamo il prossimo belle
ragazze